Put a spring in your step with SiriusXM. Our episodes deal with SiriusXM and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 8.34 on the morning of Wednesday, February 10, 1993, a call came through to the United Kingdom's emergency service helpline, 999. When the operator answered, they were met with squeals followed by muffled talking. Thinking it was a child playing a joke or calling by mistake, the operator asked, Is Mummy there? They could hear someone walking around a room on the other line while seemingly opening and closing drawers and cupboards.
让 SiriusXM 为您的生活增添活力。我们的剧集涉及 SiriusXM 以及经常令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。1993 年 2 月 10 日星期三早上 8 点 34 分，英国紧急服务热线 999 接到了一个电话。接线员接听时，听到的是尖叫声，随后是模糊的谈话声。接线员以为是个孩子在恶作剧或打错了电话，便问道：“妈妈在吗？”他们能听到电话那头有人在房间里走动，似乎还在开关抽屉和橱柜。
This continued for six minutes. The operator then noted in their system child on the line and ended the call. Although protocol dictated that these types of calls be put through to the police, nothing further was done. On the morning of Wednesday, February 10, 1993, Barbara Johnson picked up the phone and dialed the familiar number of her daughter's home line. She listened with growing frustration as she was once again met with the engaged signal. Barbara waited a few minutes before trying again. It was still engaged. Barbara was starting to get worried.
这种情况持续了六分钟。接线员随后在系统中记录了“线上有儿童”，并结束了通话。尽管协议规定此类电话应转接给警方，但之后并未采取任何行动。1993 年 2 月 10 日星期三早上，芭芭拉·约翰逊拿起电话，拨通了她女儿家熟悉的号码。她带着越来越强烈的挫败感听着，因为电话里再次传来了忙音。芭芭拉等了几分钟后又试了一次。电话依然占线。芭芭拉开始感到担忧。
She was incredibly close with her daughter, 27-year-old Nicola Fuller, and the two spoke almost to daily. But Barbara hadn't heard from Nicola since Sunday. She'd been trying to reach her since 8.45am, but almost half an hour had passed and she still couldn't get through. At 9.15, Barbara tried Nicola at work instead. Nicola was employed part-time as a sales assistant at a shopping centre not far from her home in the British market town of Wadhurst in East Sussex. But Barbara was informed that Nicola hadn't come in. Barbara tried not to worry, but she instinctively knew that something was wrong. It simply wasn't like Nicola to go three days without getting in touch with her parents.
她与 27 岁的女儿尼古拉·富勒关系极其亲密，两人几乎每天都通话。但芭芭拉自周日以来就没再收到尼古拉的消息。她从早上 8 点 45 分起就一直试图联系她，但半小时过去了，她还是打不通。9 点 15 分，芭芭拉改拨了尼古拉的工作电话。尼古拉在东萨塞克斯郡瓦德赫斯特镇（一个英国集镇）离家不远的一家购物中心担任兼职销售助理。但芭芭拉被告知尼古拉没来上班。芭芭拉尽量不去担心，但她本能地感觉到出事了。尼古拉不可能三天不与父母联系。
Nicola's home phone remained engaged all day. By the afternoon, her parents decided to stop by her home to see what was going on. Nicola lived with her husband Harry on Wadhurst's High Street. The newlyweds had recently rented Blackman's Cottage, a semi-detached three-story home nestled on a retail strip among a row of centuries-old buildings. It was a charming old residence. Painted stark white with a black roof and small front garden, the front windows overlooked the historic Main Street and surrounding shops. Guests were welcomed with a plaque adorned with two owls. It was a quintessential English cottage in a quintessential English village, with a population of only a few thousand people.
尼古拉家的电话整天都处于占线状态。到了下午，她的父母决定去她家看看发生了什么事。尼古拉和丈夫哈里住在瓦德赫斯特的高街上。这对新婚夫妇最近租下了布莱克曼小屋，这是一栋坐落在百年老建筑群中的三层半独立式住宅，位于零售街区。这是一处迷人的老宅。它漆成纯白色，配有黑色屋顶和小型前花园，前窗俯瞰着历史悠久的主街和周围的商店。客人们会受到一块装饰着两只猫头鹰的牌匾的欢迎。这是一个典型的英国村庄里典型的英国小屋，人口只有几千人。
At the rear of Blackman's Cottage was a large car park that serviced the shops and adjacent high school. Both Nicola and Harry's cars were there. Barbara Johnson and her husband Michael peered through the back door of the cottage. Their daughter's bag and car keys were sitting on a nearby table. They knocked, but there was no answer. Concern washed over the Johnson's. They called the police and requested someone conduct a welfare check. Officers arrived just before 6pm.
布莱克曼小屋的后方是一个大型停车场，为商店和邻近的高中提供服务。尼古拉和哈里的车都在那里。芭芭拉·约翰逊和她的丈夫迈克尔透过小屋的后门往里看。他们女儿的包和车钥匙放在附近的桌子上。他们敲了门，但没有人应答。约翰逊夫妇感到一阵担忧。他们报了警，要求派人进行福利检查。警察在下午 6 点前赶到。
Nicola's parents followed police to the front of the home. Everything appeared eerily quiet. The curtains were drawn and the front door was locked. Police had no choice but to break it down. Inside, everything appeared to be in place. There were no signs of a break-in or a struggle. But as officers made their way from the front lounge room to the kitchen, they noticed something sticking out from the doorway of an adjoining utility room.
尼古拉的父母跟随警察来到屋前。一切显得异常安静。窗帘拉着，前门锁着。警察别无选择，只能破门而入。屋内，一切似乎都各就各位。没有闯入或挣扎的迹象。但当警察从前厅走向厨房时，他们注意到有什么东西从相邻杂物间的门口伸了出来。
A pair of legs. In the utility room, 45-year-old Harry Fuller was sprawled on the floor in a pool of blood. His body had been propped up against the washing machine, his face covered by a leather coat. He'd been fatally shot in the back, a single bullet puncturing his heart. Police made their way upstairs. On the first floor landing, a trail of blood led them past the fallen coffee cup and ashtray into Harry and Nicola's bedroom. A blood-soaked quilt lay on the floor.
是一双腿。在杂物间里，45 岁的哈里·富勒倒在血泊中。他的身体靠在洗衣机上，脸被一件皮大衣盖住。他的后背中弹身亡，一颗子弹击穿了他的心脏。警察上了楼。在二楼平台，一条血迹引导他们经过掉落的咖啡杯和烟灰缸，进入哈里和尼古拉的卧室。地板上躺着一条浸透鲜血的被子。
Underneath was the body of Nicola Fuller. She'd been shot four times, once in the shoulder and three times in the face. Nicola's parents were quickly ushered outside. They couldn't believe what was happening. It all felt completely surreal as though they were watching a film. Nicola and Harry had only been married for five months. They'd met in June the previous year and immediately hit it off. It was an unusual pairing.
下面是尼古拉·富勒的尸体。她身中四枪，肩膀一枪，脸部三枪。尼古拉的父母被迅速带到外面。他们无法相信正在发生的事情。这一切感觉完全不真实，就像在看电影一样。尼古拉和哈里结婚才五个月。他们去年六月相识，一见钟情。这是一对不同寻常的组合。
Harry was 18 years older than Nicola and the polar opposite of her personality. While Nicola was extremely reserved and quiet, Harry was boisterous and charismatic. She preferred to fly under the radar while Harry enjoyed flaunting the finer things in life. He worked as a car dealer and loved showing off his expensive Rolls-Royce and Range Rover. But the pair brought out the best in one another and quickly fell in love. Within two months of being introduced, they were engaged. Their wedding was a modest affair. They tied the knot at a local registry office in the town of Tumbridge Wells
哈里比尼古拉大 18 岁，性格与她截然相反。尼古拉极其内向安静，而哈里则喧闹且富有魅力。她喜欢低调行事，而哈里则喜欢炫耀生活中的美好事物。他是一名汽车经销商，喜欢炫耀他昂贵的劳斯莱斯和路虎。但两人相得益彰，很快坠入爱河。相识两个月后，他们就订婚了。他们的婚礼规模不大。他们在坦布里奇韦尔斯镇的当地登记处结婚，
before having their union blessed by a reverend at St Mark's Church. Nicola's family were concerned about how quickly things progressed, but Nicola was adamant. Not only was she ready to settle down, she was incredibly happy with Harry. His zest for life was contagious and he'd helped bring Nicola out of her shell. Nicola's parents saw the positive influence Harry had on their daughter. He treated her well and was very protective of her. They ultimately welcomed Harry into their family with open arms. Blackman's Cottage was cordoned off as investigators tried to piece together the tragic events that had taken place inside.
随后由圣马可教堂的牧师为他们的结合祈福。尼古拉的家人担心事情进展太快，但尼古拉很坚定。她不仅准备好安定下来，而且对哈里感到非常幸福。他对生活的热情具有感染力，并帮助尼古拉走出了自己的壳。尼古拉的父母看到了哈里对他们女儿的积极影响。他待她很好，非常保护她。他们最终张开双臂欢迎哈里加入他们的家庭。布莱克曼小屋被封锁，调查人员试图拼凑出屋内发生的悲剧事件。
It was quickly established that the murders had occurred earlier that morning. The previous evening of Tuesday, February 9, Nicola had gone out to dinner with friends. Harry had picked her up at around 11pm. None of Nicola's friends had noticed anything unusual about the couple's behaviour. Both Nicola and Harry had been in good spirits. They'd spoken excitedly about a holiday in the Canary Islands they had planned for the following week. Located a few doors down from Blackman's Cottage was a tobacconist and news agency. On the morning of the murders, the clerk recalled that Harry Fuller came in just after 8.30 to purchase cigarettes and a newspaper.
很快确定谋杀案发生在当天早上早些时候。前一天晚上，即 2 月 9 日星期二，尼古拉和朋友们出去吃晚饭。哈里在晚上 11 点左右接她回家。尼古拉的朋友们都没有注意到这对夫妇的行为有任何异常。尼古拉和哈里当时心情都很好。他们兴奋地谈论着计划下周去加那利群岛度假的事。在布莱克曼小屋几扇门外是一家烟草店和新闻代理店。谋杀案发生的当天早上，店员回忆说哈里·富勒在 8 点 30 分刚过就进来买香烟和报纸。
Nicola's mother, Barbara, had first tried calling the Fuller's home at around 8.45am only to find the line engaged. The owners of the tea shop next door to the cottage recalled hearing three or four loud bangs around 9am, but they just thought it was the Fullers banging on the wall to tell them to turn their radio down. Investigators therefore deduced that the shootings had taken place sometime between 8.35am and 9am. Harry had been shot in the kitchen, his body then dragged to the nearby utility room. Given that he'd been shot in the back and there were no signs of a struggle, it was likely that he'd been targeted first. A strange white powder had been sprinkled over his torso. Next to Harry was a small plastic baggie containing the same substance.
尼古拉的母亲芭芭拉在早上 8 点 45 分左右第一次拨打富勒家的电话，结果发现线路占线。小屋隔壁茶店的老板回忆说，大约 9 点左右听到三四声巨响，但他们以为是富勒夫妇在敲墙，让他们把收音机声音调小。因此，调查人员推断枪击事件发生在上午 8 点 35 分至 9 点之间。哈里在厨房被枪杀，尸体随后被拖到附近的杂物间。鉴于他背部中弹且没有挣扎迹象，他很可能是第一个目标。一种奇怪的白色粉末被撒在他的躯干上。哈里旁边有一个装有同样物质的小塑料袋。
Nicola was on the first floor landing having a coffee and cigarette when the killer struck. She was still in her dressing gown and holding a towel, possibly on her way to the shower. Based on the forensics, investigators deduced that Nicola was first shot in the shoulder from behind. She then turned around to face the perpetrator only to be shot in the forehead and left cheek. These two bullets shattered her eye and splintered her skull and jaw. Still clinging to life, Nicola managed to crawl to her bedroom. The killer likely heard movements indicating that Nicola was still alive and returned to the room. They threw a quilt over her head and administered the final fatal gunshot.
尼古拉在二楼平台喝咖啡抽烟时，凶手发动了袭击。她当时还穿着晨衣，拿着毛巾，可能正要去洗澡。根据法医鉴定，调查人员推断尼古拉先是从背后被击中肩膀。她随后转身面对凶手，结果前额和左脸中弹。这两颗子弹击碎了她的眼睛，并震碎了她的头骨和下颚。尼古拉在生命垂危之际，设法爬回了卧室。凶手可能听到了表明尼古拉还活着的动静，于是回到了房间。他们把被子扔在她头上，并补上了致命的一枪。
A blood-soaked telephone handset lay next to Nicola's body, indicating that she may have tried to call for help. Given that no calls had been registered by emergency services, it appeared the shooter had killed her before she had the chance. Both Harry and Nicola had been shot at close range. A Hertenberger brand cartridge case was found outside the utility room. A ballistic expert determined that it had been fired from a .32 caliber Walther PPK self-loading pistol. Other than that, the killer left behind very few clues. A thorough search of the fuller's home failed to uncover anything significant. Nothing had been ransacked or appeared to have been stolen, leaving one investigator to conclude, quote,
尼古拉尸体旁放着一个浸满鲜血的电话听筒，表明她可能试图呼救。鉴于紧急服务部门没有登记任何通话记录，看来凶手在她有机会呼救之前就杀害了她。哈里和尼古拉都是近距离中弹。杂物间外发现了一个赫滕伯格品牌的弹壳。弹道专家确定它是从一把 .32 口径的瓦尔特 PPK 自装手枪中发射的。除此之外，凶手留下的线索很少。对富勒家的彻底搜查没有发现任何重大发现。没有任何东西被翻乱或看起来被盗，这让一位调查人员得出结论，引用：
whoever killed them did so in cold blood. Wadhurst's High Street was a busy thoroughfare that connected the counties of East Sussex and Kant. It housed a handful of restaurants, two banks, a butcher, and several other retail stores and businesses. A high school with over a thousand students was also tucked just off the main strip, just behind Blackman's Cottage, and pupils often milled around before classes started in the morning. Yet, during the crucial time window between 8.35 and 9.00 a.m., nobody had witnessed anything particularly suspicious. Police established a command centre on High Street and set up a tip line appealing for any witnesses to come forward. An investigator told the media,
“无论谁杀了他们，都是冷血所为。”瓦德赫斯特的高街是一条繁忙的通道，连接着东萨塞克斯郡和肯特郡。这里有几家餐馆、两家银行、一家肉店以及其他几家零售店和企业。一所拥有一千多名学生的高中也坐落在主街旁，就在布莱克曼小屋后面，学生们经常在早上上课前在附近徘徊。然而，在上午 8 点 35 分到 9 点之间的关键时间窗口内，没有人目击到任何特别可疑的事情。警方在高街设立了一个指挥中心，并设立了一条举报热线，呼吁任何目击者挺身而出。一位调查人员告诉媒体：
Someone out there must have seen these people coming out of this house. If we get any inkling of a description, that is really going to help us. Based on various witness reports, a timeline of events was established. At around 6.30 a.m. on the morning of the murders, a postal worker had been driving down High Street when he passed Blackman's Cottage. As usual, the road was quiet before the morning bustle commenced. The postman was therefore taken by surprise when a car pulled out in front of him from behind the Fuller's House. It was a blue Ford Escort. Behind the wheel was a well-built male driver aged between 35 and 40 years old.
“外面一定有人看到这些人从这所房子里出来。如果我们能得到任何描述的线索，那真的会对我们有很大帮助。”根据各种目击者报告，事件的时间表被确定下来。谋杀案当天早上 6 点 30 分左右，一名邮递员开车经过高街，路过了布莱克曼小屋。像往常一样，在早晨的喧嚣开始之前，道路很安静。因此，当一辆车从富勒家后面开到他面前时，邮递员感到很惊讶。那是一辆蓝色福特护卫者。驾驶座上是一名 35 到 40 岁、身材魁梧的男性司机。
The Escort continued north up the main street until disappearing out of sight. Just over half an hour later at 7.05, a passer-by on High Street saw two tall, smartly dressed men get out of a cream-coloured Ford Sierra. They walked up the path towards Blackman's Cottage, but no one saw them leave. A woman was passing the rear of the cottage just before 8 a.m. when she saw a black vehicle pull into the car park. It had a long bonnet, similar to a Jaguar. A man wearing a long black coat got out, but she didn't see where he went. Lloyd's Bank was located on the opposite side of High Street, with a security camera facing towards the tobacconist. The footage confirmed that Harry Fuller entered the tobacconist alone at 8.34 a.m., leaving just minutes later.
这辆护卫者继续向北沿主街行驶，直到消失在视线中。半个多小时后的 7 点 05 分，一名高街上的路人看到两名身材高大、衣着考究的男子从一辆奶油色的福特塞拉车中走出来。他们沿着小路走向布莱克曼小屋，但没有人看到他们离开。一名女子在早上 8 点前经过小屋后方时，看到一辆黑色车辆驶入停车场。它有一个长引擎盖，类似于捷豹。一名穿着长黑大衣的男子走了出来，但她没看到他去了哪里。劳埃德银行位于高街对面，有一个对着烟草店的监控摄像头。录像证实哈里·富勒在上午 8 点 34 分独自进入烟草店，几分钟后离开。
He didn't appear to have been followed, and nothing else suspicious was captured on the tape. However, a Jaguar XJS was confirmed to be in the area. A schoolgirl walked past Blackman's Cottage at around 9 a.m. She told police that she heard a door slam and someone then bumped into her. When she looked up, she saw another man standing by the cottage door. Based on this and the report of the two men seen getting out of the Ford Sierra, police considered the possibility that there were two killers. However, the schoolgirl had been accompanied by a friend who had a different recollection. She said these events had occurred on different days rather than simultaneously.
他似乎没有被跟踪，录像带中也没有捕捉到其他可疑情况。然而，一辆捷豹 XJS 被证实出现在该地区。一名女学生在上午 9 点左右经过布莱克曼小屋。她告诉警察，她听到关门声，然后有人撞到了她。当她抬头看时，她看到另一个男人站在小屋门口。基于此以及关于两名男子从福特塞拉车上下来的报告，警方考虑了有两名凶手的可能性。然而，这名女学生当时由一名朋友陪同，该朋友有不同的回忆。她说这些事件发生在不同的日子，而不是同时发生的。
News of the murders shocked the community. Not only was Wadhurst considered to be a quiet, safe village, locals couldn't believe that a seemingly normal couple could be the targets of such a heinous crime. Although Harry and Nicola were relatively new to the area and mostly kept to themselves, there was nothing about them that raised any red flags. That was until police started digging into Harry's background, and another pitcher emerged entirely. Harry Fuller hadn't done very well at school. He was dyslexic, which meant he struggled with reading and writing. But Harry thrived in other areas. He had the gift of the gab, was good with his hands, and always recognized a good deal.
谋杀案的消息震惊了社区。瓦德赫斯特不仅被认为是一个安静、安全的村庄，当地人也无法相信一对看似正常的夫妇会成为如此令人发指的罪行的目标。虽然哈里和尼古拉对该地区来说相对陌生，而且大多保持低调，但他们身上没有任何引起红旗的事情。直到警方开始挖掘哈里的背景，另一幅画面才完全浮出水面。哈里·富勒在学校表现并不好。他有阅读障碍，这意味着他在阅读和写作方面很吃力。但哈里在其他领域表现出色。他能说会道，动手能力强，总能识别出好买卖。
Using these skills to his advantage, he worked in the building and roofing trade before moving into car dealing. He attended auctions and networked, buying used cars he could later sell for a profit. The business served him well. The only problem was finding somewhere to store the vehicles. When Blackman's Cottage became available, Harry was elated. It meant he'd have access to the large car park at the rear of the property. But he seemed to be wary about the move. Neighbours noticed that he wouldn't open the front door without looking out the window first, and he only opened the door for people he knew.
利用这些技能，他在建筑和屋顶行业工作，随后转入汽车交易。他参加拍卖会并建立人脉，购买二手车，然后再转手获利。这门生意对他很有利。唯一的问题是找地方存放车辆。当布莱克曼小屋空出来时，哈里欣喜若狂。这意味着他可以使用房产后部的大型停车场。但他似乎对这次搬迁很谨慎。邻居们注意到，他不看窗外就不会开前门，而且他只为认识的人开门。
It was possible that he was just being overly cautious. Most of Harry's business transactions were done in cash, and he wasn't shy about showing it off. Friends and associates said Harry didn't even bother to carry a wallet, instead carrying briefcases and bank rolls full of cash. Given the white powder that was scattered over Harry's body, the obvious theory was that the murders could have been drug related. Investigators considered the possibility that Harry's car dealings were just a front for an illegal cocaine operation. Some of his business associates had checkered pasts, and one was rumoured to have served prison time for manslaughter. Even Harry himself had previous run-ins with the law, with prior convictions for dishonesty and burglary. Some who knew Harry described him as a con man. He was a big talker who liked to exaggerate things, particularly when it came to his wealth.
他可能只是过于谨慎。哈里的大部分商业交易都是用现金完成的，他不介意炫耀这一点。朋友和同事说，哈里甚至懒得带钱包，而是随身携带装满现金的公文包和银行卷。鉴于撒在哈里尸体上的白色粉末，最明显的理论是谋杀案可能与毒品有关。调查人员考虑了哈里的汽车交易只是非法可卡因行动的幌子的可能性。他的一些商业伙伴有复杂的过去，其中一人据传曾因过失杀人罪入狱。甚至哈里本人也有过与法律的冲突，有欺诈和入室盗窃的前科。一些认识哈里的人形容他是个骗子。他是个大话连篇的人，喜欢夸大其词，尤其是在谈到自己的财富时。
Former neighbours accused Harry of having conned them out of money by conducting seemingly free repairs to their homes, which he then charged them exorbitantly for. Harry had voiced concerns about his past to a business associate. He was worried that there were certain individuals who might feel compelled to track him down. It quickly became clear that Harry was paranoid about something. The fullers had only been living in Blackman's cottage for five months, but police discovered that Harry had already changed their phone number three times in that period. The most recent just a week before the murders. Given there were no signs of a break-in, police were convinced that Harry likely knew his killer and had willingly let them inside. The white powder found on Harry's body was taken for testing. It wasn't cocaine at all, but sugar. With no other evidence to support the drug theory, it was quickly ruled out. But the sugar did provide a clue.
以前的邻居指责哈里通过对他们的房屋进行看似免费的维修，然后收取高额费用来欺骗他们。哈里曾向一位商业伙伴表达过对自己过去的担忧。他担心有些人可能会觉得有必要追踪他。很快就很清楚，哈里对某事感到偏执。富勒夫妇在布莱克曼小屋只住了五个月，但警方发现哈里在此期间已经三次更换了电话号码。最近的一次就在谋杀案发生前一周。鉴于没有闯入迹象，警方确信哈里很可能认识凶手，并自愿让他们进屋。在哈里尸体上发现的白色粉末被送去化验。那根本不是可卡因，而是糖。由于没有其他证据支持毒品理论，它很快被排除。但糖确实提供了一条线索。
It meant that whoever had killed the fullers had likely premeditated the crime, sprinkling the sugar over Harry's body as a red herring. Not long before the murders, Harry had bought a BMW from another car dealer, which he intended to sell. However, he discovered that the engine and license plates had been changed, till tale signs that the car was stolen. Harry was indignant. He reported the theft to the police, which ultimately led them to uncover a car-ringing operation. As a result of the bust, some of Harry's business associates lost money. They were not happy. The decision to report the theft came back to haunt Harry. Just five days before he was killed, Harry told an officer that one of his embittered associates, Roger Lee, suspected that Harry was the snitch and had started giving him trouble. Roger Lee was a car dealer and reputed gangster with a proclivity for violence and cocaine. He was known to carry around a shotgun, which he wasn't afraid to threaten people with.
这意味着杀害富勒夫妇的人很可能是预谋犯罪，将糖撒在哈里尸体上作为转移视线的幌子。在谋杀案发生前不久，哈里从另一位汽车经销商那里买了一辆宝马，打算转卖。然而，他发现发动机和车牌都被改动过，这是车辆被盗的明显迹象。哈里很愤怒。他向警方报告了盗窃案，这最终导致他们发现了一个汽车团伙。由于这次突击行动，哈里的一些商业伙伴损失了钱财。他们很不高兴。举报盗窃案的决定最终困扰了哈里。就在他被杀前五天，哈里告诉一名警官，他的一位怀恨在心的合伙人罗杰·李怀疑哈里是告密者，并开始给他制造麻烦。罗杰·李是一名汽车经销商，也是著名的黑帮分子，有暴力和可卡因倾向。他以随身携带猎枪而闻名，并不怕用它威胁别人。
He also drove a Jaguar XJS, similar to that captured in the Lloyds Bank security footage. Investigators considered the possibility that Roger Lee had gone to the fuller's house to seek revenge on Harry. They tracked him down to a caravan roughly 20 miles from Wadhurst. Lee was uncooperative and refused to answer any questions. He quickly became the number one person of interest, but with no evidence to tie him to the crimes, police had no grounds to make an arrest. Posters appealing for information were plastered at the car auction sites that Harry frequented, but within days of the murders, investigators were considering another angle altogether. By all accounts, Harry and Nicola had been happily married, but if history was anything to go by, some reported that infidelity could be at play. This wasn't Harry's first marriage. He'd only recently gotten divorced and had a three-year-old daughter with his ex-wife.
他还开着一辆捷豹 XJS，类似于劳埃德银行监控录像中捕捉到的那辆。调查人员考虑了罗杰·李去富勒家向哈里寻求报复的可能性。他们追踪到他位于距离瓦德赫斯特约 20 英里处的一个大篷车里。李不配合，拒绝回答任何问题。他很快成为头号嫌疑人，但由于没有证据将他与罪行联系起来，警方没有理由逮捕他。呼吁提供信息的传单贴在哈里经常光顾的汽车拍卖场，但在谋杀案发生后的几天内，调查人员正在考虑另一个角度。据各方说法，哈里和尼古拉婚姻幸福，但如果历史可以作为参考，一些人报告说可能存在不忠行为。这不是哈里的第一次婚姻。他最近才离婚，并与前妻有一个三岁的女儿。
There were also unconfirmed reports of a third failed marriage. Harry was widely known to be a lady's man. With his head of dark hair, traditional good looks and roguish ways, many women found him to be very charming. One friend told today that Harry, quote, had a finger in every pie going. Police couldn't find any evidence that Harry was unfaithful to Nicola. On the contrary, people noted that he was incredibly protective of his new wife. He took great care of her and put her on a pedestal. He was always buying her gifts and sending her flowers.
还有未经证实的第三次婚姻失败的报道。哈里被广泛认为是花花公子。凭借他那一头黑发、传统的英俊外表和流氓作风，许多女性发现他非常有魅力。一位朋友告诉《今日》，哈里“什么事都插一脚”。警方找不到任何证据表明哈里对尼古拉不忠。相反，人们注意到他非常保护他的新婚妻子。他非常照顾她，把她捧在手心里。他总是给她买礼物，送她鲜花。
Prior to their wedding, the couple had met with a priest. Harry told him that he was looking forward to a fresh start with Nicola. Nicola's family loved Harry, but as the skeletons emerged from his closet, they found it difficult not to blame him for what happened to their beloved Nikki. They had no doubt that Nicola was completely unaware of Harry's business dealings and shady past. Nicola's father, Michael, described his daughter as an English rose, saying, She would never do anything to hurt someone. She would have been totally devastated by all of this. Police considered whether Harry and Nicola could have been the victims of a contract killing. Had a vengeful business associate hired someone to take Harry out and Nicola was unfortunate enough to be collateral damage.
在婚礼前，这对夫妇见过一位牧师。哈里告诉他，他期待与尼古拉有一个新的开始。尼古拉的家人爱哈里，但随着他衣柜里的秘密浮出水面，他们发现很难不责怪他给他们心爱的尼基带来的后果。他们毫不怀疑尼古拉完全不知道哈里的商业交易和阴暗过去。尼古拉的父亲迈克尔形容他的女儿是一朵“英国玫瑰”，说：“她永远不会做任何伤害别人的事。她会被这一切彻底摧毁。”警方考虑哈里和尼古拉是否可能是合同谋杀的受害者。是一个复仇心切的商业伙伴雇人除掉哈里，而尼古拉不幸成了附带损害。
Or had a scorned lover sought the ultimate revenge on an unfaithful partner. The lead investigator told the media, The nature of the killings means the possibility that we are looking at a professional murder cannot be ruled out. The killer was certainly ruthless in the way he executed his crime. Harry's family shied away from the media, but on February 15, five days after the murders, Nicola's parents, Michael and Barbara Johnson appeared at a press conference appealing for anyone with information to come forward. Barbara sobbed quietly as Michael struggled to get out the words. His voice shaking, he said.
还是一个被抛弃的情人对不忠的伴侣寻求了终极报复。首席调查员告诉媒体：“谋杀的性质意味着我们正在调查职业谋杀的可能性不能被排除。”凶手在执行犯罪时确实冷酷无情。哈里的家人避开了媒体，但在 2 月 15 日，即谋杀案发生五天后，尼古拉的父母迈克尔和芭芭拉·约翰逊出席了新闻发布会，呼吁任何有信息的人挺身而出。芭芭拉低声啜泣，迈克尔努力说出话来。他声音颤抖地说：
Whoever killed Harry, Nicola was an innocent witness. Both families are totally devastated. Please come forward and trust the police. I can see no reason why there should be anything to fear. Meanwhile, police obtained Roger Lee's mobile phone records from the morning of Wednesday, February 10, 1993. Data confirmed he was nowhere near Wadhurst at the time. What initially seemed like a promising lead was yet another in a long line of red herrings. Blackman's Cottage became a makeshift memorial as grieving loved ones and shocked members of the community visited to place flowers on the doorstep.
“无论谁杀了哈里，尼古拉都是无辜的目击者。两个家庭都彻底崩溃了。请挺身而出，相信警察。我看不到有任何理由需要害怕。”与此同时，警方获得了罗杰·李 1993 年 2 月 10 日星期三早上的手机记录。数据显示他当时根本不在瓦德赫斯特附近。起初看起来很有希望的线索，又是众多转移视线的幌子之一。布莱克曼小屋成为了一个临时纪念地，悲痛的亲人和震惊的社区成员纷纷前来在门口献花。
Inside, the search for clues continued. Police were especially interested in finding where Harry stashed his money. Harry had recently gone into business with one of his neighbors. The woman told police that just 10 days before the murders, she gave Harry £13,000 in cash, a majority of which was in £20 notes. The plan was simple. Harry would use the money to buy cars, which he'd sell. The two would then split the profits down the middle. In the days following this handover, Harry hadn't made any large bank deposits or significant purchases.
在屋内，寻找线索的工作仍在继续。警方特别有兴趣找到哈里藏钱的地方。哈里最近与他的一位邻居合伙做生意。这位女士告诉警察，就在谋杀案发生前 10 天，她给了哈里 13,000 英镑现金，其中大部分是 20 英镑的钞票。计划很简单。哈里将用这笔钱买车，然后转卖。两人随后平分利润。在这次移交后的几天里，哈里没有进行任何大额银行存款或重大购买。
It therefore made sense to assume that at least some of the money would be in his house. But police couldn't find any sign of it. Despite Harry's reputation for flashing briefcases full of money, all they found was a grand total of £210. However, the search didn't cover something else of interest. Under a couch in the lounge room, police found an old G-Mark brand answering machine. Under another couch was a Boots brand answering machine. Pressing play on the tapes, it became apparent that the Fullers had been recording all of their recent phone calls. Although no one close to the couple had any explanation as to why they might be doing this, the content of the tapes provided some fascinating insights.
因此，假设至少部分钱会在他家里是合理的。但警察找不到任何迹象。尽管哈里以携带装满钱的公文包而闻名，但他们只发现了总共 210 英镑。然而，搜查并没有覆盖其他感兴趣的东西。在客厅的一张沙发下，警察发现了一台旧的 G-Mark 品牌答录机。在另一张沙发下是一台 Boots 品牌答录机。按下磁带上的播放键，很明显富勒夫妇一直在录制他们最近所有的电话。虽然这对夫妇的亲近的人都没有解释他们为什么要这样做，但磁带的内容提供了一些迷人的见解。
Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. The Boots answering machine contained several conversations and messages, most of which were run-of-the-mill exchanges between friends, family, and business associates, except one. Harry, at column, the final, undated message said, I'm going to come around tomorrow and we're going to have a serious talk about what you did to me tonight. I'm pretty pissed off with you, and you're going to pay for it. The caller was identified as Colin Gabriel, a former car-dealing business partner of Harry Fullers. Police tracked Colin down and asked him about the threatening message. Colin explained that roughly three months earlier, around November of 1992, he and Harry had a falling out.
案件档案很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Case File 继续提供高质量的内容。Boots 答录机包含了几次对话和留言，其中大部分是朋友、家人和商业伙伴之间的普通交流，除了一个。哈里，在专栏中，最后一条未注明日期的留言说：“我明天会过来，我们要好好谈谈你今晚对我做的事。我对你很生气，你会为此付出代价的。”打电话的人被确认为科林·加布里埃尔，哈里·富勒以前的汽车交易商业伙伴。警察找到了科林，询问了那条威胁信息。科林解释说，大约三个月前，即 1992 年 11 月左右，他和哈里闹翻了。
He said he'd left the message around that time, and the two had nothing to do with one another since. Although there was nothing to verify when Colin had left the message, police didn't find anything else to link him to the crime, and he was deemed an unlikely suspect. They hoped a conversation recorded on the other GMAC answering machine would prove more fruitful. The 49 minutes of audio recordings on this device had all been captured within two days of Harry and Nicola's deaths. One conversation had been recorded the night before, while Nicola had been out dining with friends. In it, Harry sounded jovial and good-natured as the male caller asked him how he was doing. Very well indeed, Harry responded. Couldn't be better. The man told Harry that he'd popped over to see him the previous evening at around 7 o'clock.
他说他在那个时候留下了那条信息，此后两人就再也没有任何往来。虽然没有任何东西可以核实科林是什么时候留下那条信息的，但警方没有发现任何其他东西将他与罪行联系起来，他被认为不太可能是嫌疑人。他们希望录在另一台 GMAC 答录机上的对话能证明更有成效。该设备上的 49 分钟录音都是在哈里和尼古拉去世前两天内捕捉到的。其中一段对话是在前一天晚上录制的，当时尼古拉正和朋友们出去吃饭。在录音中，当男性来电者问他过得怎么样时，哈里听起来很愉快且随和。“确实非常好，”哈里回答。“再好不过了。”那个人告诉哈里，他前一天晚上 7 点左右去看了他。
The lights were on, so he knocked, but there was no answer. Harry said he'd been at the gym. The two then arranged a meeting for 8 o'clock the following morning. The man agreed to come to the fuller's home. Harry responded warmly. You're a gentleman. Don't let me down. See you in the morning, my darling. The caller was equally cheerful, ending the conversation by saying, Ciao for now.
灯亮着，所以他敲了门，但没有人应答。哈里说他在健身房。两人随后安排了第二天早上 8 点的会面。那个人同意来富勒家。哈里热情地回应。“你是个绅士。别让我失望。明早见，亲爱的。”打电话的人同样开朗，结束对话时说：“先再见。”
Although it was a casual, seemingly light-hearted conversation between friends, it raised some red flags. Harry Fuller wasn't known to be a morning person, so why was he agreeing to such an early morning meeting? Furthermore, if the caller had indeed visited the fuller's home at 8am as the pair planned, it'd put him at the scene of the crime within the key time period of the murders. While this didn't necessarily mean the caller was involved, it meant they could be a vital witness. All investigators had to go by was the caller's first name, Steve. He was the only caller on the GMAC answering machine who they couldn't identify. They began compiling a list of all the steves known to Harry Fuller,
虽然这是一次朋友之间随意的、看似轻松的对话，但它引发了一些红旗。哈里·富勒并不以早起的人而闻名，那么他为什么要同意这么早的会议呢？此外，如果打电话的人确实像两人计划的那样在早上 8 点访问了富勒家，那他就会在谋杀案的关键时间段出现在犯罪现场。虽然这并不一定意味着打电话的人参与其中，但这意味着他们可能是一个至关重要的目击者。调查人员所能依靠的只有打电话者的名字，史蒂夫。他是 GMAC 答录机上唯一一个他们无法确认身份的来电者。他们开始编制一份哈里·富勒认识的所有史蒂夫的名单，
or anyone with that name who may have come into contact with Harry in recent times. Given that the fullers had only changed their phone number the week before the murders, it meant only a select few had been given their latest number. But with such a large network of friends, acquaintances and associates, the list of potential steves soon grew to dozens of individuals. Police attempted to track down and question each one while keeping their knowledge of the recorded phone call a secret. Each one denied having any knowledge of Harry or Nicola's death. A £10,000 reward for information was announced, but still the mysterious Steve remained silent.
或者任何可能在最近接触过哈里的同名人士。鉴于富勒夫妇在谋杀案发生前一周才更换了电话号码，这意味着只有少数人得到了他们的最新号码。但随着如此庞大的朋友、熟人和同事网络，潜在的史蒂夫名单很快增加到几十人。警方试图追踪并询问每一个人，同时对他们所知道的录音电话保密。每个人都否认知道哈里或尼古拉的死讯。宣布了 10,000 英镑的悬赏金，但神秘的史蒂夫依然保持沉默。
The reality was that no matter how beloved Harry Fuller was, he also had an abundance of enemies. The various lines of inquiry made it difficult to ascertain which was the right path. While police had no shortage of leads, three weeks passed with no major breakthroughs. They sent a letter to every household in Wadhurst providing an update on the case and continuing their appeal for information. Then, one investigating officer had an idea. He picked up the telephone handset that had been found beside Nicola Fuller's body and pressed the redial button. Perhaps it would lead them to Steve or to another key person Harry or Nicola might have spoken to prior to the crime. The answer on the other end of the line surprised him.
现实情况是，无论哈里·富勒多么受人喜爱，他也有大量的敌人。各种调查路线使得很难确定哪条是正确的道路。虽然警方不乏线索，但三周过去了，没有任何重大突破。他们给瓦德赫斯特的每一户人家写了一封信，提供了案件的最新进展，并继续呼吁提供信息。然后，一位调查警官有了一个主意。他拿起在尼古拉·富勒尸体旁发现的电话听筒，按下了重拨键。也许它会引导他们找到史蒂夫或哈里或尼古拉在犯罪前可能交谈过的另一个关键人物。电话那头的回答让他大吃一惊。
Emergency, which service? There hadn't been any record of an emergency 999 call being placed from Blackman's Cottage. Neither police nor paramedics had been summoned to the property on the morning that Harry and Nicola were killed. Investigators now realised that Nicola might have succeeded in calling for help after all. They obtained a recording of the calls that had come through to 999 on Wednesday, February 10, 1993. At 8.34am, a call was placed from Blackman's Cottage. The caller didn't speak and only made squealing sounds down the receiver. The answering emergency services operator interpreted these sounds to be that of a child playing around and disconnected the call.
“紧急情况，什么服务？”没有任何记录显示从布莱克曼小屋拨打了 999 紧急电话。在哈里和尼古拉被杀的当天早上，警察和医护人员都没有被传唤到该房产。调查人员现在意识到尼古拉可能确实成功呼救了。他们获得了 1993 年 2 月 10 日星期三拨打 999 的电话录音。上午 8 点 34 分，从布莱克曼小屋拨出了一个电话。打电话的人没有说话，只是在听筒里发出尖叫声。接听的紧急服务接线员将这些声音解释为孩子在玩耍，并断开了通话。
Police realised the muffled cries had actually been Nicola Fuller. The gunshot to her head that had shattered her jaw had also severed her tongue. She was trying to ask the operator for help but was unable to speak clearly. It was while she had the operator on the line that the killer placed a quilt over Nicola's head and administered the final fatal gunshot. Not knowing where the call had gone through, the killer continued walking around the house, opening and closing drawers. When Nicola's family found out about this, they were shattered. The Wadhurst police station was roughly 200 yards from Blackman's Cottage. If Nicola's call had been patched through, they believed she could have been saved,
警察意识到那些模糊的哭声实际上是尼古拉·富勒。她头部中弹，下颚碎裂，舌头也被切断了。她试图向接线员求助，但无法清晰说话。就在她与接线员通话时，凶手把被子盖在尼古拉头上，并补上了致命的一枪。不知道电话打到了哪里，凶手继续在屋里走动，开关抽屉。当尼古拉的家人发现这件事时，他们崩溃了。瓦德赫斯特警察局距离布莱克曼小屋大约 200 码。如果尼古拉的电话被转接，他们相信她本可以获救，
or at the very least, the killer could have been caught in the act. Nicola's parents met with British Telecom, the company responsible for handling the calls, demanding an explanation and public apology. The request was denied. By April 1993, two months had passed since the double homicide and police were no closer to making an arrest. They decided it was time to reveal their full hand. A segment about the case was aired on CrimeWatch, a popular BBC television program that created reconstructions of major unsolved crimes. In it, police released an edited audio clip of Harry Fuller talking to the elusive Steve, with Steve's name cut out. A detective who worked on the case told viewers,
或者至少，凶手本可以在作案时被抓获。尼古拉的父母会见了负责处理这些电话的公司英国电信，要求解释并公开道歉。请求被拒绝。到 1993 年 4 月，双重谋杀案已经过去两个月了，警方离逮捕凶手还很远。他们决定是时候亮出底牌了。关于此案的一个片段在 BBC 的热门电视节目《犯罪观察》上播出，该节目制作了重大未决案件的重演。在节目中，警方发布了一段哈里·富勒与难以捉摸的史蒂夫交谈的剪辑音频，其中史蒂夫的名字被剪掉了。一位参与此案的侦探告诉观众：
It's absolutely crucial that we find this man. We haven't found him, and he hasn't come forward. There may be some reason for that, but we really need to find him, and I'd ask anybody that's listening tonight who either recognises his voice, or thinks they recognise his voice, to please make contact with us. Alternatively, if the man concerned is listening and he himself wants to contact us to eliminate him, then please do contact us. A woman named Sheila was watching the segment at home. She thought she recognised the voice as her brother-in-law, Steve Young, but she couldn't be sure. Sheila decided to sleep on it.
“找到这个人绝对至关重要。我们还没有找到他，他也没有挺身而出。这可能有某种原因，但我们真的需要找到他，我会要求今晚收听的任何要么认出他的声音，要么认为自己认出他的声音的人，请与我们联系。或者，如果相关男子正在收听，并且他自己想联系我们以排除嫌疑，那么请联系我们。”一位名叫希拉的女士正在家里看这个片段。她认为她认出了那个声音是她的姐夫史蒂夫·杨，但她不能确定。希拉决定再考虑一下。
The next day, she called Steve Young and asked if he had spoken to Harry Fuller on the night before the murders. Steve said no. Sheila was baffled. The voice had sounded so much like him. She urged her brother-in-law to contact the police anyway, just to eliminate himself from the investigation. Steve Young was Harry's insurance broker. The two had known each other since the early 80s, but had lost touch over the years. They'd only recently run into each other again and started a business relationship. About two weeks into the Fuller murder inquiry, police had questioned Steve Young as part of the routine probe into Harry's business dealings.
第二天，她打电话给史蒂夫·杨，问他是否在谋杀案发生前一天晚上与哈里·富勒交谈过。史蒂夫说没有。希拉感到困惑。那个声音听起来太像他了。她敦促她的姐夫无论如何都要联系警察，只是为了排除自己的嫌疑。史蒂夫·杨是哈里的保险经纪人。两人从 80 年代初就认识，但多年来失去了联系。他们最近才再次相遇，并开始了业务关系。在富勒谋杀案调查进行到大约两周时，警方曾作为对哈里商业交易常规调查的一部分询问过史蒂夫·杨。
Steve said their relationship was purely professional. They didn't have a friendship outside of work. They'd last spoken about five days before the murders, when Harry called Steve to discuss a cover note that was about to expire. Steve claimed he was in his office on the morning of Wednesday, February 10, 1993, and that his secretary could verify his whereabouts. There was nothing about him that aroused police suspicions, so he wasn't looked into any further. But Sheila wasn't the only one who recognized the voice. Around the same time, an anonymous mail called the police tip line stating, The voice is Steve Young. Two days after the crime watch episode aired, two officers were dispatched to interview Steve Young at his office.
史蒂夫说他们的关系纯粹是职业性的。他们在工作之外没有友谊。他们最后一次交谈是在谋杀案发生前五天，当时哈里打电话给史蒂夫讨论一份即将到期的保险单。史蒂夫声称他在 1993 年 2 月 10 日星期三早上在办公室，他的秘书可以证明他的行踪。他身上没有任何引起警方怀疑的地方，所以他没有被进一步调查。但希拉并不是唯一一个认出那个声音的人。大约在同一时间，一名匿名邮件拨打了警方举报热线，称：“那个声音是史蒂夫·杨。”在《犯罪观察》剧集播出两天后，两名警官被派往史蒂夫·杨的办公室对他进行采访。
Before they had the chance, they were called back. Young had just walked into the Sussex police station and identified himself as the caller on the tape. He'd also handed police a two-page statement in which he admitted that he'd initially lied to the interviewing officers. Young explained that one of his clients had a Porsche they wanted to sell. He'd told Harry Fuller about it, and he was interested in checking it out. On the evening of Tuesday, February 9, Young called Harry to arrange an inspection for 8am the following day. As Young made his way to Wadhurst the next morning, he was unexpectedly held up by roadworks. By the time he arrived at Blackman's Cottage, it was around 20 past eight.
在他们有机会之前，他们就被召回了。杨刚走进萨塞克斯警察局，并确认自己就是录音中的那个打电话的人。他还向警方递交了一份两页的声明，承认自己最初对审讯人员撒了谎。杨解释说，他的一位客户有一辆保时捷想卖。他告诉了哈里·富勒这件事，哈里很有兴趣去看看。2月9日星期二晚上，杨打电话给哈里，安排在第二天早上8点进行检查。第二天早上，当杨前往瓦德赫斯特时，意外地被道路施工耽搁了。当他到达布莱克曼小屋时，大约是8点20分。
The curtains were drawn, so he assumed the Fullers were still asleep. Young said he knocked on the door, but there was no answer. He walked down High Street to waste some time before returning to Blackman's Cottage at around 8.40am. The curtains were still drawn, and again his knocks went unanswered. Steve Young was adamant he hadn't seen or heard anything suspicious at the property. When he found out that Harry and Nicola had been murdered, he was shocked. He claimed to have contacted the police to see if they wanted to question him, but his call was never returned, so he just assumed his statement wasn't of any interest. By the time police visited him as part of their routine questioning, he'd heard about Harry's shady business dealings.
窗帘拉着，所以他以为富勒夫妇还在睡觉。杨说他敲了门，但没有人应答。他在大街上走了一会儿，消磨时间，然后在大约早上8点40分回到布莱克曼小屋。窗帘仍然拉着，他的敲门声再次无人应答。史蒂夫·杨坚称他在那处房产没有看到或听到任何可疑的事情。当他得知哈里和尼古拉被谋杀时，他感到非常震惊。他声称曾联系警方，看他们是否想审问他，但他的电话从未得到回复，所以他只是认为他的陈述没有任何价值。当警方作为例行询问的一部分拜访他时，他已经听说了哈里那些不正当的商业交易。
Young claimed he lied about his whereabouts on the day of the murders because he was afraid for his own safety. For investigators, there was nothing about Steve Young that raised any red flags. Aged in his mid-30s, the married father of two was a well-educated, law-abiding citizen with no criminal record. By all accounts, he was a doting husband and supportive parent. A pillar of the community, he helped to run his son's under-11 football team and was enthusiastically involved in the local drama club. Just a few months earlier, he'd stolen the show with his comedic acting skills during the village's Christmas pantomime. He was respected by the community and clients alike. Still, it was hard to comprehend why he hadn't approached the police straight away.
杨声称他在谋杀案发生当天对自己行踪撒谎是因为他担心自己的人身安全。对于调查人员来说，史蒂夫·杨身上没有任何引起怀疑的地方。这位30多岁的已婚父亲是两个孩子的父亲，是一位受过良好教育、守法的公民，没有犯罪记录。据各方说法，他是一位疼爱妻子的丈夫和支持孩子的父亲。作为社区的中坚力量，他帮助管理儿子的11岁以下足球队，并热情地参与当地的戏剧俱乐部。就在几个月前，他在村里的圣诞哑剧中以其喜剧表演技巧抢尽了风头。他受到社区和客户的尊敬。尽管如此，很难理解他为什么没有立即联系警方。
The officer who questioned Young early on in the investigation had noted him as relaxed and normal, with nothing in his demeanour arousing any suspicion. They couldn't help but wonder if he had something to hide. Steve Young agreed to be formally interviewed. He admitted that he probably wouldn't have come forward if the recording of his call with Harry hadn't been aired on Crime Watch. Given that he hadn't seen anything that could help with the investigation, he simply didn't want to be involved in any way. When asked whether he had access to any firearms, Young said he was the treasurer of a local rifle club. He owned several guns, each of which were legally licensed, a shotgun, a revolver, and three pistols. None of them were 32-caliber pistols, the type used in the fuller murders.
在调查初期审问杨的警官指出，他表现得很放松、很正常，没有任何举止引起怀疑。他们不禁怀疑他是否有什么隐瞒。史蒂夫·杨同意接受正式审问。他承认，如果他和哈里的通话录音没有在《犯罪观察》节目中播出，他可能不会主动站出来。鉴于他没有看到任何有助于调查的事情，他只是不想以任何方式卷入其中。当被问及是否可以使用任何枪支时，杨说他是当地一家步枪俱乐部的财务主管。他拥有几支枪，每一支都有合法执照，包括一把霰弹枪、一把左轮手枪和三把手枪。它们都不是富勒谋杀案中使用的那种32口径手枪。
Even though they had no evidence to link him to the crime, police suspected Steve Young knew more than he was letting on. They placed him under arrest while further investigation was conducted, treading carefully with Young in a bid to keep him talking. Police looked in to Steve Young's movements on Wednesday, February 10. After leaving Blackman's Cottage, it was a typical working day for the insurance broker. He had some meetings, spoke with some business associates, and chatted on the phone with his wife. In the evening, he attended a meeting at the Freemasons Lodge, where he was a member. He'd been his normal self. Nobody had noticed anything strange about his behaviour. A warrant was obtained to search Young's home and office.
尽管没有任何证据将他与犯罪联系起来，但警方怀疑史蒂夫·杨知道的比他透露的要多。他们在进行进一步调查时将他逮捕，并小心翼翼地对待杨，试图让他继续开口。警方调查了史蒂夫·杨在2月10日星期三的行踪。离开布莱克曼小屋后，对于这位保险经纪人来说，这是典型的工作日。他开了一些会，与一些商业伙伴交谈，并与妻子通了电话。晚上，他参加了共济会分会的一次会议，他是那里的成员。他表现得和平常一样。没有人注意到他的行为有什么奇怪之处。警方获得了搜查杨家和办公室的搜查令。
While he'd already admitted to being a gun enthusiast who was legally licensed to own multiple weapons, police were shocked at what they found. In addition to the firearms Young had already disclosed, they found deactivated grenade launchers, bayonets, replica submachine guns, combat gear, masks, and even fake number plates. One of the illegal guns, a loaded 9mm automatic pistol, had been stashed underneath the bed of one of Young's children. The search also uncovered thousands of rounds of ammunition. When the collection of arsenal was laid out, it filled the size of a squash cord. While this was deeply troubling, one weapon was notably absent, a .32 caliber pistol. Young had already told police that he topped up his ammunition supply by reloading. This is a common practice used by gun enthusiasts to save money.
虽然他已经承认自己是一名枪支爱好者，并合法拥有多件武器，但警方对他所发现的东西感到震惊。除了杨已经披露的枪支外，他们还发现了已失效的榴弹发射器、刺刀、仿制冲锋枪、作战装备、面具，甚至还有假车牌。其中一把非法枪支，一把装满子弹的9毫米自动手枪，被藏在杨的一个孩子床下。搜查还发现了数千发弹药。当这些军火被摆出来时，填满了壁球场那么大的空间。虽然这非常令人不安，但有一件武器明显缺失，那就是一把32口径的手枪。杨此前曾告诉警方，他通过重新装填来补充弹药供应。这是枪支爱好者为了省钱而常用的做法。
Instead of purchasing mass-produced ammunition, one can collect empty cases and then assemble the individual components, including gunpowder, primers, and bullet heads. Police found Young's reloading machine. The markings on his reloaded ammunition was compared to the ammunition recovered from Blackman's cottage. They looked remarkably similar. When the police asked Young what car he drove to Blackman's cottage, he was oddly cagey. He ummed and arred before saying it was probably his white Volkswagen Golf. The police looked for the car at Young's home and office. It wasn't there.
与其购买批量生产的弹药，不如收集空弹壳，然后组装各个部件，包括火药、底火和弹头。警方发现了杨的复装机。他复装弹药上的标记与从布莱克曼小屋回收的弹药进行了比对。它们看起来非常相似。当警方问杨他开车去布莱克曼小屋时开的是什么车时，他表现得异常闪烁其词。他支支吾吾，然后说可能是他的白色大众高尔夫。警方在杨的家和办公室寻找这辆车。它不在那里。
They asked him where it was, and he said he'd recently taken it to a mechanic to have some work done. Police tracked the Golf down, only to discover that Young had only taken it in the day after the segment about the Fuller's murders had aired on CrimeWatch. A mobile telephone inside the vehicle was confirmed to have made a call to the Fuller's home at 8.10 on the morning of the murders. Although the Volkswagen Golf was a popular model, Young's vehicle was unique looking with distinct modifications, including alloy wheels. This made it easy for investigators to differentiate it from other white cars when reviewing the security footage taken from Lloyd's bank. They focused on the times that Steve Young claimed to have arrived and departed from the area, 8.20 and 8.40 am. But there was no sign of the Golf. They viewed the footage captured earlier and later than the times Young had given.
他们问他车在哪里，他说他最近把它送到修理厂去维修了。警方追踪到了那辆高尔夫，却发现杨是在《犯罪观察》播出关于富勒谋杀案的片段后的第二天，才把它送去修理的。车内的一部移动电话被证实曾在谋杀案当天早上8点10分拨打过富勒家。虽然大众高尔夫是一款流行的车型，但杨的车辆外观独特，有明显的改装，包括合金轮毂。这使得调查人员在查看劳埃德银行的监控录像时，很容易将其与其他白色汽车区分开来。他们重点关注了史蒂夫·杨声称到达和离开该地区的时间，即早上8点20分和8点40分。但没有高尔夫的踪影。他们查看了杨提供的时间之前和之后的录像。
Sure enough, they found the car. He'd been caught in yet another lie. With the circumstantial evidence mounting against Steve Young, the biggest question was, why would he want to kill Harry and Nicola Fuller? He had no known grudges with either of them, nor was there anything to suggest any kind of romantic involvement. In fact, he barely knew them. Police asked Young about his financial situation. He responded it was pretty tight. This soon proved to be a major understatement.
果然，他们找到了那辆车。他又一次撒谎被抓住了。随着针对史蒂夫·杨的间接证据越来越多，最大的问题是，他为什么要杀害哈里和尼古拉·富勒？他与他们两人之间没有已知的恩怨，也没有任何迹象表明有任何形式的浪漫关系。事实上，他几乎不认识他们。警方询问了杨的财务状况。他回答说非常紧张。这很快被证明是一个严重的轻描淡写。
Steve Young was deep in debt. He'd inherited his home from his father, but had since taken out several mortgages, which had overdue payments. His insurance brokerage was trading insolvently and hadn't turned a profit in 8 years. Instead of using his client's money to pay their insurance premiums, Young was using it to pay off his own debts. With no funds left over to pay the insurance companies, his brokerage was under threat of being shut down. His financial situation was deemed critical. All up, Young owed over £100,000 to multiple friends, family members and businesses. The provincial insurance company was one such business.
史蒂夫·杨债台高筑。他从父亲那里继承了房子，但此后又申请了几笔抵押贷款，这些贷款都有逾期还款。他的保险经纪公司经营不善，已经8年没有盈利了。杨没有用客户的钱支付他们的保险费，而是用它来偿还自己的债务。由于没有剩余资金支付给保险公司，他的经纪公司面临倒闭的威胁。他的财务状况被认为是危急的。总而言之，杨欠多位朋友、家人和企业超过10万英镑。省保险公司就是其中之一。
Young owed them £13,500 in back-dated premiums. Police discovered that just two days before Harry and Nicola were killed, a representative from provincial had called Young. He said he'd be coming to Young's office on Wednesday, February 10 to collect the outstanding debt. If he didn't pay up, they'd no longer do business with him. The appointment went ahead as planned. Young handed over a check for £6,000, which cleared with no problems. Police discovered that Young kept a detailed record of all the people he borrowed money from. There was no record of him having borrowed a large sum of money before this meeting.
杨欠他们13500英镑的过期保费。警方发现，就在哈里和尼古拉被杀的前两天，省保险公司的一名代表曾给杨打过电话。他说他将于2月10日星期三来到杨的办公室收取欠款。如果他不付钱，他们将不再与他做生意。预约按计划进行。杨交出了一张6000英镑的支票，支票顺利兑现了。警方发现，杨详细记录了他借钱的所有人。在这次会议之前，没有他借过大笔钱的记录。
This raised the obvious question. Where did he get his money from? A check of Steve Young's bank records confirmed that he'd deposited £6,000 into his business account on the morning of Wednesday, February 10, just after Harry and Nicola were killed. The deposit was made in £20 notes, just like the unaccounted for payment that Harry Fuller had received from his neighbour. Young had also paid off an outstanding phone bill of £360. The police asked Young where he got this cash from. He explained that a friend had lent it to him two years ago and he'd been hanging onto it in case of an emergency. Meanwhile, an officer searching Young's office found a single 32-caliber Hertenberger bullet. A ballistics expert examined it and determined it had been shot from a Walther PPK self-loading pistol.
这引出了一个显而易见的问题。他的钱是从哪里来的？对史蒂夫·杨银行记录的核查证实，他在2月10日星期三早上，也就是哈里和尼古拉被杀后不久，向他的商业账户存入了6000英镑。这笔存款是用20英镑面值的钞票存入的，就像哈里·富勒从邻居那里收到的那笔无法解释的款项一样。杨还偿还了360英镑的逾期电话费。警方问杨这些现金是从哪里来的。他解释说，一位朋友两年前借给他的，他一直留着以备不时之需。与此同时，一名搜查杨办公室的警官发现了一颗32口径的赫滕伯格子弹。弹道专家检查后确定它是从瓦尔特PPK自装手枪中射出的。
The same as the gun used to kill Harry and Nicola Fuller. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. When pressed, Young maintained his innocence. He explained that he'd once reloaded some 32-caliber ammunition for another member of his gun club but had never owned such a weapon himself. It was no use. He'd been caught in too many lies. Steve Young was formally charged with the double murder of Harry and Nicola Fuller. Police dubbed him the Ice Man for the way he was able to go about his life immediately after the crimes as though nothing had happened.
与杀死哈里和尼古拉·富勒的枪相同。案件档案很快就会回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Case File继续提供高质量的内容。当被追问时，杨坚称自己是无辜的。他解释说，他曾经为枪支俱乐部的另一名成员复装过一些32口径的弹药，但自己从未拥有过这样的武器。没用了。他撒了太多的谎。史蒂夫·杨被正式指控犯有哈里和尼古拉·富勒的双重谋杀罪。警方称他为“冰人”，因为他在犯罪后能够立即像什么都没发生一样继续他的生活。
Harry and Nicola's families were stunned. Young lived just down the road from Harry's brother, Tom, and they sometimes ran into each other at the local pub. He couldn't believe that such an apparently normal person could commit such a heinous crime. To Nicola's family, Young was a complete stranger. Her sister Michelle told Crime Watch, I found it hard to believe that their insurance broker would have access to guns, let alone that he would commit such a crime. It didn't seem to fit the character or the sort of person you assume an assurance broker to be. But then, what is a murderer like? What job do they do?
哈里和尼古拉的家人惊呆了。杨就住在哈里的兄弟汤姆家附近，他们有时会在当地的酒吧碰面。他无法相信一个看起来如此正常的人竟然能犯下如此令人发指的罪行。对于尼古拉的家人来说，杨是一个完全的陌生人。她的妹妹米歇尔告诉《犯罪观察》：“我很难相信他们的保险经纪人会接触到枪支，更不用说他会犯下这样的罪行。这似乎不符合性格，也不符合你认为保险经纪人应该是的那种人。但话说回来，杀人犯是什么样的？他们做什么工作？”
In the first week of May, three months after they were killed, Harry and Nicola were laid to rest in separate ceremonies. Their funerals suited their personalities. Harry's a large event and Nicola's modest and private. Nicola's funeral took place the day after Harry's at the same church where the pair's marriage had been blessed just eight months prior. The presiding reverend told the Kent and Sussex courier, You cannot make sense of a nonsense like this. It is hard to do anything other than stand together in sorrow and sadness. Steve Young's trial for the double murder commenced in late February 1994 and just over a year after Harry and Nicola were killed. The prosecution's case was relatively straightforward. While the evidence against Young was circumstantial, they said his dire financial situation gave him motivation to target Harry Fuller, who was known to carry large sums of cash.
5月的第一周，在他们被杀三个月后，哈里和尼古拉在单独的仪式上入土为安。他们的葬礼符合他们的个性。哈里的葬礼规模宏大，尼古拉的则朴素而私密。尼古拉的葬礼在哈里的葬礼后一天举行，地点就在八个月前这对夫妇举行婚礼祝福的同一座教堂。主持的牧师告诉《肯特和萨塞克斯信使报》：“你无法理解这样的荒唐事。除了在悲伤和哀痛中站在一起，很难做任何其他事情。”史蒂夫·杨的双重谋杀案审判于1994年2月下旬开始，距离哈里和尼古拉被杀仅一年多一点。检方的案子相对简单。虽然针对杨的证据是间接的，但他们表示，他糟糕的财务状况给了他针对哈里·富勒的动机，因为哈里以携带大量现金而闻名。
By setting up a meeting with Harry about his client's Porsche, he established an explanation for his presence at Blackman's Cottage. His access to firearms gave him the means to carry out the crime, while the discovery of similar bullets to those used in the murders proved a link. His changing stories and the lies he told to police were further proof of his guilt. Nicola Fuller was a victim of collateral damage. Young had shot her purely to avoid her identifying him as her husband's killer. The defense disputed this entirely. If Young's sole motive was financial gain, there were plenty of other people who could have targeted Harry Fuller for this same reason. What about his other enemies and scorned business associates? And if all Young wanted was a quick cash grab, why not break in and rob Blackman's Cottage when nobody was home?
通过安排与哈里会面讨论他客户的保时捷，他为自己出现在布莱克曼小屋找到了解释。他接触枪支的途径给了他实施犯罪的手段，而发现与谋杀案中使用的子弹相似的子弹证明了联系。他不断变化的说法和对警方撒的谎是他有罪的进一步证明。尼古拉·富勒是附带损害的受害者。杨射杀她纯粹是为了避免她认出他是她丈夫的杀手。辩方完全反驳了这一点。如果杨唯一的动机是经济利益，那么还有很多人可以因为同样的原因针对哈里·富勒。他其他的敌人和被轻视的商业伙伴呢？如果杨想要的只是快速抢钱，为什么不在没人时闯入并抢劫布莱克曼小屋呢？
If Nicola wasn't a target, why didn't he organise to meet Harry at a different location or when he was alone? The courtroom was tense as Steve Young took the stand in his own defense. In an unexpected twist, he provided a brand new account of the events that unfolded on the morning of February 10. For the first time, Young gave an explanation for the 8.10am phone call between himself and Harry Fuller. He claimed that he called Harry upon his arrival to Blackman's Cottage because the curtains were all drawn and there was no response when he knocked on the door. The call apparently woke Harry up. Harry told Young to give him some time, so Young waited in his car. A short while later, he noticed that a curtain had been opened. He knocked again but still there was no response. He walked to the rear of the property in case Harry had decided to wait for him in the car park.
如果尼古拉不是目标，为什么他不安排在不同的地点或在他独自一人时与哈里会面？当史蒂夫·杨为自己的辩护出庭作证时，法庭气氛紧张。在一个意想不到的转折中，他提供了关于2月10日早上发生事件的全新叙述。杨第一次解释了自己和哈里·富勒之间早上8点10分的电话。他声称，他在到达布莱克曼小屋时给哈里打了电话，因为窗帘都拉着，他敲门时没有人回应。这个电话显然把哈里吵醒了。哈里告诉杨给他一点时间，所以杨在车里等。过了一会儿，他注意到窗帘被拉开了。他又敲了一次门，但仍然没有人回应。他走到房产后面，以防哈里决定在停车场等他。
When he got there, he saw that the back door was slightly open. Young looked inside and saw Harry lying on the ground. He rushed inside and felt for a pulse, but there wasn't one. At first, he assumed Harry had a heart attack, but he then noticed blood was coming from Harry's head. A cartridge case was lying nearby. From his experience with guns, Young said he recognized it as being from a 32 calibre bullet. For the first time, Young admitted that he had once owned a replica .32 Walther PPK pistol. He said he'd purchased it from a Chinese mail order five years prior, but had since sold it to someone else – Harry Fuller.
当他到达那里时，他看到后门微微敞开。杨往里看，看到哈里躺在地上。他冲进去摸了摸脉搏，但没有脉搏。起初，他以为哈里心脏病发作了，但他随后注意到哈里的头部在流血。附近躺着一个弹壳。根据他的枪支经验，杨说他认出那是32口径子弹的弹壳。杨第一次承认他曾经拥有一把仿制.32瓦尔特PPK手枪。他说他是五年前从一家中国邮购公司购买的，但后来把它卖给了别人——哈里·富勒。
Young claimed that in the months before Harry was killed, he and another man approached Young at his office, asking if he could help Harry purchase a gun for protection. Young sold him the Walther PPK, along with some of his reloaded ammunition. Young said that upon realizing Harry was dead, he panicked. He immediately fled outside. Looking back at the house, he saw an unfamiliar face of a boarding male in the upstairs window. Young dialed 999, but then paused. Harry Fuller had been killed by the very weapon that Young had sold him illegally. Fearing that he'd be incorrectly linked to the crime or that his life would be in danger for being a witness, he made the difficult decision to keep what he saw to himself.
杨声称，在哈里被杀前的几个月里，他和另一个男人在办公室找到杨，问他是否能帮助哈里购买一把枪用于自卫。杨把瓦尔特PPK卖给了他，还有一些他复装的弹药。杨说，当意识到哈里死了，他惊慌失措。他立即逃到外面。回头看房子时，他看到楼上的窗户里有一个陌生的男人的脸。杨拨打了999，但随后停顿了。哈里·富勒是被杨非法卖给他的武器杀死的。由于担心自己会被错误地与犯罪联系起来，或者因为作为目击者而生命受到威胁，他做出了一个艰难的决定，将他所看到的一切保密。
In the weeks following, Young said that an anonymous male called his office multiple times making threats against him and his family. His fear was so immense that he was compelled to lie and put on a façade of calm when questioned by the police. The defence presented the possibility that another of Harry's enemies had entered Blackman's cottage that morning. Perhaps Harry had drawn his gun on the assailant, who managed to take hold of the weapon themselves, and then used it to kill the couple. The prosecution disputed this. Had someone gone to the Fuller's home with the intention to kill, common sense dictated that they would have brought their own weapon. Also, Harry had been shot from behind at close range. It was unlikely he would have turned his back while a gun was being aimed at him.
在接下来的几周里，杨说一个匿名男子多次给他的办公室打电话，威胁他和他的家人。他的恐惧如此强烈，以至于他在接受警方询问时被迫撒谎并装出一副冷静的样子。辩方提出了哈里的另一个敌人那天早上进入布莱克曼小屋的可能性。也许哈里对袭击者拔出了枪，袭击者设法夺取了武器，然后用它杀死了这对夫妇。检方反驳了这一点。如果有人带着杀人的意图去富勒家，常识告诉他们会带上自己的武器。此外，哈里是从背后近距离被射杀的。他不太可能在有人瞄准他时背对着对方。
Young's story about selling Harry his Walther PPK along with some of his reloaded ammunition also seemed suspiciously convenient. He'd only mentioned this after becoming aware of the fact that 32 caliber ammo had been uncovered in his office. After four weeks of testimony, the jury deliberated overnight before delivering its verdict. For the murders of Harry and Nicola Fuller, Steve Young was found guilty and given two life sentences. A motion in the courtroom was mixed. Some of the victim's loved ones cheered while Young's wife broke down in tears. Although Nicola's family were relieved, her father told reporters, the verdict doesn't change things for us at all. We can't bring Nicci back, but this does take an evil person off the streets. Harry and Nicola's loved ones could finally begin the healing process.
杨关于卖给哈里瓦尔特PPK以及一些复装弹药的故事看起来也极其巧合。他只有在意识到他的办公室里发现了32口径弹药后才提到这一点。经过四周的证词，陪审团彻夜商议后作出了裁决。对于哈里和尼古拉·富勒的谋杀案，史蒂夫·杨被判有罪，并被判处两次终身监禁。法庭上的反应不一。一些受害者的亲人欢呼雀跃，而杨的妻子则泪流满面。虽然尼古拉的家人感到宽慰，但她的父亲告诉记者：“判决对我们来说根本没有改变任何事情。我们无法让尼基回来，但这确实把一个邪恶的人从街上带走了。”哈里和尼古拉的亲人终于可以开始愈合过程了。
But for one member of the jury, the nightmare was just beginning. For weeks after the trial, 24 year old juror Adrian lay awake at night, plagued with a secret. Something had happened during the trial that didn't sit well with him. He was torn. Did he keep it to himself, or did others have the right to know the truth? Adrian deliberated internally before eventually seeking legal advice. Most solicitors didn't want to get involved, likely because it was illegal to repeat anything that jurors told them. But as the weeks went by, Adrian could no longer live with the knowledge of what had happened behind closed doors. The night before Steve Young's verdict was delivered, the 12 member jury had been sequestered to a hotel to deliberate.
但对于陪审团的一名成员来说，噩梦才刚刚开始。审判后的几周里，24岁的陪审员阿德里安晚上躺在床上睡不着觉，被一个秘密所困扰。审判期间发生了一些让他感到不安的事情。他很纠结。他是应该把它藏在心里，还是其他人有权知道真相？阿德里安在内心挣扎后，最终寻求了法律建议。大多数律师不想卷入其中，很可能是因为重复陪审员告诉他们的任何事情都是违法的。但随着几周过去，阿德里安再也无法忍受闭门造车所发生的事情的真相。在史蒂夫·杨的判决宣布的前一天晚上，12名陪审员被隔离在一家酒店进行商议。
This is standard practice in many countries. It ensures that jurors have minimal access to the outside world, thus preventing exposure to external influences or information while they reach a decision. It had been a long four weeks for the jurors. Not only were they conflicted as to whether or not Steve Young was telling the truth, they'd also had to sit through the six minute recording of Nicola Fuller's thwarted attempt to call for help. It took an emotional toll. Once the jurors were in the hotel, they sat down over dinner and had a few drinks to try and unwind. The atmosphere quickly became more relaxed. People joked around and engaged in casual conversation, lifting the mood considerably.
这是许多国家的标准做法。它确保陪审员与外界的接触最少，从而防止在达成决定时接触到外部影响或信息。对于陪审员来说，这是漫长的四周。他们不仅在史蒂夫·杨是否说真话的问题上存在分歧，还不得不坐着听完尼古拉·富勒试图呼救的六分钟录音。这造成了情感上的伤害。陪审员们进入酒店后，坐下来吃晚饭，喝了几杯酒，试图放松一下。气氛很快变得更加轻松。人们开玩笑，进行随意的交谈，气氛大为好转。
An entertaining conversation arose about seances and who among them had participated in one before. A seance is a meeting in which people attempt to communicate with the spirit world. While the concept of contacting the dead has been around for centuries, it wasn't until the late 1800s that the very first device was sold to facilitate communication between the living and deceased. Known as a Ouija board, the device consists of a flat board displaying all the letters of the alphabet, the numbers zero through nine, and the words yes, no, and goodbye. At the bottom is a small heart-shaped plank known as the planchette. To use a Ouija board, two or more people gather round the board, gently placing their hands on the planchette. They then ask questions and watch as the planchette moves around the board, spilling out messages from the other side. The Ouija board is a controversial device.
一个关于降神会以及他们中谁以前参加过降神会的有趣谈话出现了。降神会是人们试图与灵界交流的会议。虽然接触死者的概念已经存在了几个世纪，但直到19世纪末，第一台促进生者与死者之间交流的设备才被出售。这种设备被称为通灵板，由一块平坦的板子组成，上面显示了所有字母表、数字0到9以及“是”、“否”和“再见”等词。底部是一块心形的小木板，称为指针。要使用通灵板，两个或更多人围在板子周围，轻轻地将手放在指针上。然后他们提出问题，看着指针在板子上移动，拼出来自另一边的信息。通灵板是一种有争议的设备。
Some view it as a valuable means to communicate with the spirit world, while others believe it's a satanic tool that can open menacing portals into the unknown. Scientists believe the so-called messages received on a Ouija board are simply the result of the user's subconscious. To skeptics, the planchette isn't moved across the board by a spiritual being, but by the users themselves. Whatever the truth, most people tend to agree on one thing. Ouija boards are not to be messed with. The group of jurors laughed and shared stories about their experience with seances before retiring to their rooms for the 11pm curfew. Adrienne was feeling quite tipsy and went straight to bed. But a small group, one man and three women, weren't ready to call it a night. Intrigued by the conversation about seances, they gathered in one of their hotel rooms and decided to hold one of their own. They fashioned their very own Ouija board out of paper using a wine glass as the planchette.
有些人认为它是与灵界交流的宝贵手段，而另一些人则认为它是可以打开通往未知世界的威胁性门户的撒旦工具。科学家认为，在通灵板上收到的所谓信息仅仅是用户潜意识的结果。对于怀疑论者来说，指针不是由灵体在板子上移动的，而是由用户自己移动的。无论真相如何，大多数人倾向于同意一件事。通灵板是不能乱玩的。这群陪审员笑着分享了他们参加降神会的经历，然后回到房间遵守晚上11点的宵禁。阿德里安喝得有点醉，直接上床睡觉了。但一小群人，一名男子和三名女子，还没准备好结束这一夜。被关于降神会的谈话所吸引，他们聚集在其中一个酒店房间里，决定自己举行一次。他们用纸制作了自己的通灵板，用酒杯作为指针。
The foursome then sat around the board, each of them placing their fingers on the base of the glass. They asked if there were any spirits present. The answer was yes. The group asked the spirit to identify themselves. The planchette moved across the board from letter to letter, finally spelling out the name Harry Fuller. The group grew tense. The designated leader asked, who killed you? They watched in silence as the wine glass slid across the board, eventually spelling out the words, Stephen Young did it.
四个人围坐在板子周围，每个人都把手指放在杯底。他们问是否有任何灵体在场。答案是肯定的。小组要求灵体表明身份。指针在板子上从一个字母移动到另一个字母，最后拼出了“哈里·富勒”的名字。小组变得紧张起来。指定的领导者问：“是谁杀了你？”他们静静地看着酒杯在板子上滑动，最终拼出了“史蒂夫·杨干的”这些字。
The leader asked what they should do. The response, vote guilty tomorrow. For some of the women, it became too much. They started to cry, thinking they'd taken things way too far. The seance ended and the group retreated to their respective rooms, tormented by what they'd done. The next morning, Adrian heard them discussing it over breakfast. He couldn't believe they'd actually gone through with it. At first, he thought it was funny. But, when Steve Young was declared guilty later that day, Adrian wondered whether a miscarriage of justice had been served.
领导者问他们该怎么办。回答是：“明天投有罪票。”对于一些女性来说，这太过分了。她们开始哭泣，认为自己把事情做得太过火了。降神会结束了，小组成员退回到各自的房间，被他们所做的事情折磨着。第二天早上，阿德里安听到他们在早餐时讨论这件事。他无法相信他们真的这么做了。起初，他觉得这很有趣。但是，当史蒂夫·杨当天晚些时候被宣布有罪时，阿德里安怀疑是否发生了司法不公。
Four weeks after the trial, Adrian couldn't live with the knowledge anymore. He wrote an anonymous letter to the Crown Court, detailing the antics at the hotel and requesting that Steve Young's conviction be quashed. Shortly after, he approached the News of the World tabloid and gave them the full exclusive story, saying, This is someone's life we're dealing with. I was astonished that these grown-up people had played this child's game. News of the World published the story under the headline, Boo's Dirty Jokes and the Ouija Board. It quickly became a media sensation. A jury is expected to reach a verdict based on the facts presented at trial, not on potentially unreliable external information.
审判结束四周后，阿德里安再也无法忍受这个秘密了。他给刑事法庭写了一封匿名信，详细描述了酒店里的闹剧，并要求撤销史蒂夫·杨的定罪。不久之后，他联系了《世界新闻报》小报，并给了他们完整的独家报道，说：“这是我们正在处理的某人的生命。我感到震惊的是，这些成年人竟然玩了这个孩子的游戏。”《世界新闻报》以“嘘声、脏笑话和通灵板”为标题发表了这篇报道。它很快成为媒体轰动事件。陪审团应根据审判中提出的事实达成裁决，而不是根据可能不可靠的外部信息。
Being swayed by external influence or attempting to acquire further evidence was potentially a criminal offence. Adrian's allegations were therefore treated with utmost seriousness. A full investigation was launched to determine whether those who held the seance had attempted to pervert the course of justice. The four jury members insisted that the decision to use the Ouija Board had been nothing more than a poor decision fueled by alcohol. Despite some of their emotional reactions, they each viewed the whole thing as a joke and were adamant that the answers given by the so-called spirit had nothing to do with their decision to convict Steve Young. It took six months of questioning and deliberations before the court declared that while the jury had misbehaved, nothing criminal had occurred. Steve Young's legal team appealed his conviction based in part on the jury's misbehavior and the court agreed. A retrial was ordered. The court's opinion provoked some fascinating discussions for the legal community.
受到外部影响或试图获取进一步证据可能是一种刑事犯罪。因此，阿德里安的指控受到了极其严肃的对待。一项全面的调查启动，以确定那些举行降神会的人是否试图妨碍司法公正。四名陪审员坚持认为，使用通灵板的决定只不过是一个受酒精影响的糟糕决定。尽管他们中的一些人有情绪反应，但他们每个人都把整件事看作是一个玩笑，并坚称所谓灵体给出的答案与他们定罪史蒂夫·杨的决定无关。经过六个月的询问和商议，法院宣布，虽然陪审团行为不端，但没有发生任何犯罪行为。史蒂夫·杨的法律团队部分基于陪审团的不当行为对他的定罪提出上诉，法院同意了。法院下令重审。法院的意见在法律界引发了一些引人入胜的讨论。
Law professor Gary Slapper discussed the issue in the Times newspaper, saying, Suppose the jurors in the hotel had sought advice from their God through prayer. Would such a course of action invalidate their decision? They would, after all, be consulting something non-corporeal and something other than the evidence in the case. The divine and superstitious oracles both rely on the faith of the juror. Will the court of appeal be able to argue that consulting a God for guidance is permissible, but that consulting any other non-corporeal entity is not allowed? Harry and Nicholas' families were eager to put the trauma of the trial behind them and move on with their lives. When they heard that Young's conviction was overturned, they were gutted. Harry's family couldn't believe that a man proven guilty in court could get a retrial on what they viewed as such a, quote, silly, silly thing. Nicholas' family didn't think they could get through it a second time around. They were furious that the media had latched onto the sensational Ouija board story, saying that the jurors had made a complete mockery of their daughter's death.
法学教授加里·斯拉珀在《泰晤士报》上讨论了这个问题，他说：“假设酒店里的陪审员通过祈祷寻求上帝的建议。这样的行动会使他们的决定无效吗？毕竟，他们会咨询非物质的东西，而不是案件中的证据。神圣和迷信的预言都依赖于陪审员的信仰。上诉法院能否辩称，咨询上帝寻求指导是允许的，但咨询任何其他非物质实体是不允许的？”哈里和尼古拉的家人渴望将审判的创伤抛在脑后，继续他们的生活。当他们听说杨的定罪被推翻时，他们感到非常痛苦。哈里的家人无法相信一个在法庭上被证明有罪的人，竟然能因为他们认为如此“愚蠢、愚蠢的事情”而获得重审。尼古拉的家人认为他们无法第二次经历这一切。他们对媒体抓住耸人听闻的通灵板故事感到愤怒，称陪审员完全嘲弄了他们女儿的死。
The retrial of Steve Young for the murders of Harry and Nicholas Fuller went ahead eight months later in front of a brand new jury. For three weeks, Harry and Nicholas loved ones had to endure the harrowing evidence for a second time. But once again, the jury unanimously found Steve Young guilty for both murders. The judge called him a cold-blooded killer who had committed the crimes for his own personal gain before serving him with two life sentences. When asked if he had anything to say, Young simply stated, I'm innocent, my lord. Outside court, Harry's brother Tom told reporters, Steven Young is an animal who should be put down. I would like to see hanging brought back for people like him.
史蒂夫·杨因谋杀哈里和尼古拉·富勒的重审在八个月后在全新的陪审团面前进行。三周来，哈里和尼古拉的亲人不得不第二次忍受令人痛苦的证据。但陪审团再次一致裁定史蒂夫·杨两项谋杀罪名成立。法官称他为冷血杀手，为了个人利益犯下了这些罪行，随后判处他两次终身监禁。当被问及有什么话要说时，杨只是简单地说：“法官大人，我是无辜的。”法庭外，哈里的兄弟汤姆告诉记者：“史蒂夫·杨是一个应该被处死的畜生。我希望看到像他这样的人被恢复绞刑。”
You can hardly explain what it has been like for both families to go through this ordeal. It's like someone having their hand in your guts and slowly pulling them out. Some struggled to comprehend that an upstanding family man like Steve Young could be compelled to commit such a callous crime, no matter his motivation. Theories remained that he wasn't the only one at the Fuller's house on February 10, 1993. There was still the matter of the witnesses who had reported seeing two mysterious men approaching Blackman's Cottage on the morning of the murders. Although these sightings were never confirmed, it fueled ongoing speculation that Steve Young could have been working with one of Harry Fuller's enemies, either by force or out of financial desperation. Given Young's access to firearms, his clean criminal record, and his rapport with Harry, Young arguably made a desirable partner for someone who wanted to cause more harm to Harry than simply taking his money. It was even theorized that Young could have agreed to help set up the meeting, not knowing what was about to transpire. But no evidence was ever uncovered to support this, and no one else was ever charged in relation to the crime.
你很难解释两个家庭经历这种磨难是什么感觉。就像有人把手伸进你的内脏里慢慢地把它们拉出来一样。一些人难以理解像史蒂夫·杨这样受人尊敬的顾家男人，无论动机如何，怎么会被迫犯下如此冷酷的罪行。理论仍然认为，1993年2月10日，他并不是唯一一个在富勒家的人。还有目击者报告说，在谋杀案当天早上看到两名神秘男子接近布莱克曼小屋。虽然这些目击事件从未得到证实，但这助长了持续的猜测，即史蒂夫·杨可能与哈里·富勒的敌人之一合作，无论是被迫还是出于经济绝望。鉴于杨接触枪支的途径、他干净的犯罪记录以及他与哈里的融洽关系，对于那些想对哈里造成比仅仅拿走他的钱更大的伤害的人来说，杨可以说是一个理想的伙伴。甚至有人推测，杨可能同意帮助安排会面，却不知道接下来会发生什么。但从未发现任何证据支持这一点，也没有其他人因该罪行被起诉。
The trial of Steve Young has made history as one of the high-profile examples of juror misbehavior. Decades later, the behavior of the jurors is still questioned. Harry Fuller's brother Tom felt the original jurors should be punished for what they did, saying, We all went through months more agony because of them. Detective Graham Hill, who worked on the Fuller murder investigation, told the ABC, This is making an absolute mockery, and it's the most serious type of trial you can ever have. There is no element of humour in it at all, there's no frivolity in it at all, and yet those four members of the jury made it into a laughing stock. University of Melbourne law professor Jeremy Gans wrote a book centered around the case, titled The Ouija Board Jurors, Mystery, Mischief and Misery in the Jury System. In it, he explores other cases of jury misconduct, concluding that there was nothing exceptional about the Ouija Board jurors other than the tabloid media attention.
史蒂夫·杨的审判作为陪审员不当行为的高调案例之一载入史册。几十年后，陪审员的行为仍然受到质疑。哈里·富勒的兄弟汤姆认为最初的陪审员应该因为他们的所作所为而受到惩罚，他说：“因为他们，我们所有人都经历了几个月的痛苦。”参与富勒谋杀案调查的侦探格雷厄姆·希尔告诉澳大利亚广播公司：“这简直是在嘲弄，这是你所能经历的最严重的审判。它没有任何幽默成分，没有任何轻浮成分，然而那四名陪审员却把它变成了一个笑柄。”墨尔本大学法学教授杰里米·甘斯写了一本以该案为中心的书，题为《通灵板陪审员：陪审团制度中的神秘、恶作剧和苦难》。在书中，他探讨了其他陪审团不当行为的案例，得出的结论是，除了小报媒体的关注外，通灵板陪审员没有什么特别之处。
Gans disputes the general perception that the jurors were making a mockery of the Fuller case and treating the hotel sequestering as a party. Instead, he points out that they had to sit through disturbing evidence, including the failed 999 call from Nicola, which would have been incredibly traumatic. Professor Gans told the ABC, Whatever was going on in that hotel room probably wasn't good times for the jury, but perhaps something else, coping with what they were hearing. Gans' book also provided a revelation. In 2004, Young's new defence team hired a forensic audiologist to analyse the six minute recording of the 999 call placed by Nicola Fuller. They determined that after Nicola was killed, footsteps of two different people could be heard rummaging around Blackman's Cottage, whispering to one another. While the whispers were unintelligible, one word was clear.
甘斯反驳了陪审员嘲弄富勒案并将酒店隔离视为派对的普遍看法。相反，他指出他们不得不坐着听令人不安的证据，包括尼古拉失败的999电话，这会让人感到难以置信的创伤。甘斯教授告诉澳大利亚广播公司：“那个酒店房间里发生的任何事情可能对陪审团来说都不是美好的时光，但也许是别的什么，是在应对他们所听到的事情。”甘斯的书还提供了一个启示。2004年，杨的新辩护团队聘请了一位法医听力学家来分析尼古拉·富勒拨打的999电话的六分钟录音。他们确定，在尼古拉被杀后，可以听到两个不同的人在布莱克曼小屋里翻找，互相耳语。虽然耳语听不清楚，但有一个词很清楚。
Here. The stress of Nicola's death and the ongoing litigation took an enormous toll on the health of her parents, Barbara and Michael, who were both aged in their mid 50s. Within a two year period of the legal proceedings, Barbara suffered from a heart attack and Michael from a serious stroke. They missed Nicola immensely. Small things served as daily reminders from her favourite songs to the way she always buzzed in any patch of sun she could find. Barbara told Crime Watch When I sit out there, in my garden in the sunshine, I think I can see her there in the lounger. Nicola's sister Michelle looked after her parents while also trying to manage her own grief.
“这里”。尼古拉去世的压力和持续的诉讼对她父母芭芭拉和迈克尔的健康造成了巨大的伤害，他们都已年过半百。在法律程序进行的两年内，芭芭拉患上了心脏病，迈克尔患上了严重的中风。他们非常想念尼古拉。小事成了她每天的提醒，从她最喜欢的歌到她总是嗡嗡作响地寻找任何阳光斑点的方式。芭芭拉告诉《犯罪观察》：“当我坐在花园里的阳光下时，我想我能看到她躺在躺椅上。”尼古拉的妹妹米歇尔在照顾父母的同时，也试图管理自己的悲伤。
Nicola was haunted by nightmares of her sister's final moments, telling Crime Watch that the thought of Nicola crawling to the phone for help that never came kept her awake night after night. Michelle said At least 100 times a day, I want to pick up the phone to Nicola, or I think I must tell Nicola that, but I don't accept that she's not there. I have to accept that one day I'll see her. I get through each day on the strength that one day, I'll be able to ask her how she is. Thanks for watching! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
尼古拉被她姐姐最后时刻的噩梦所困扰，告诉《犯罪观察》，尼古拉爬向电话寻求永远不会到来的帮助的想法让她夜不能寐。米歇尔说：“每天至少有100次，我想拿起电话打给尼古拉，或者我想我必须告诉尼古拉这件事，但我无法接受她不在那里。我必须接受有一天我会见到她。我靠着有一天我能问她过得好不好的力量度过每一天。”感谢观看！本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。